Five years ago,
I was on this stage
to talk about the relationships
between humans and machines.
Today, I'm here to talk only
about the relationships between humans.
I regularly say
in my lectures on artificial intelligence
that humans will always have
a monopoly on evil.
It's not a threat,
just a reminder that people choose.
We are not algorithms.
We are not bound by code
or commandments or laws or treaties.
We have them.
But we choose.
So let us talk now
about the choices we make.
About things in black and white.
About Russia's war on Ukraine.
And about good and evil.
My life experience prepared me
to identify evil at an early age.
Not my life as the chess player.
Not even as the youngest
world champion in history.
No.
My relevant experience
is where I was born and raised,
in what Ronald Reagan
accurately called the “evil empire,”
the USSR.
As a young star in the chess-crazed
Soviet Union in the ’70s and ’80s,
I had many privileges
my compatriots did not.
I could travel to the West
outside of the Iron Curtain,
where it was obvious to me very quickly
that they were the free world
and we were not,
despite what communist propaganda told us.
I eventually got into trouble
for sharing these views.
What late American civil rights hero
and Congressman John Lewis
would have called “good trouble.”
My criticism of the Soviet system
and my praise for America was bad enough.
But it was even worse
because where it was published.
[“Playboy” Interview: Garry Kasparov]
(Laughter)
My comments were almost
as [much of] a scandal
as Soviet movie star Natalya Negoda’s
nude photos in “Playboy” in the same year.
I felt I had to speak out
to use my fame to push
the envelope of free speech
in Gorbachev's collapsing empire.
The next year, in October 1990,
in my world championship match
against Anatoly Karpov in New York City,
I refused to play
under Soviet hammer and sickle
and demanded to play under Russian flag.
The USSR staggered on for another year
until it disintegrated
on Christmas Day, 1991.
Oh, what a great moment
in world history.
How we celebrated,
the evil empire had fallen,
the future looked bright.
And yet, eight years later,
on December 31, 1999,
a former lieutenant colonel of the KGB
became the president of Russia.
His name was Vladimir Putin.
How this happened
is a long, painful story.
And in fact, I wrote a book about it
in 2015 called "Winter is Coming."
Not an original title, I have to admit.
(Laughter)
But I'm a fan of "Game of Thrones."
And also I felt it was appropriate
because it was a warning.
The subtitle was more important:
"Why Vladimir Putin and the Enemies
of the Free World Must Be Stopped."
The publisher, by the way, didn't like it.
"Enemies."
It's too harsh.
Sounded like Cold War.
"Absolutely," I said.
"Cold War because winter is coming."
(Laughter)
Well, here we are, seven years later.
And if I wrote a sequel,
it would be called “Winter Is Here.”
And the subtitle would be
"I Bleeping Told You So."
(Laughter)
Actually, my first article of warning
was published in
“The Wall Street Journal”
on January 4, 2001.
I saw evil because I heard evil.
Putin was telling us what he was.
All we had to do was listen.
When Putin said that there was
no such thing as a former KGB agent,
I knew Russia's fragile
democracy was in danger.
When Putin said that the collapse
of the Soviet Union
was the greatest geopolitical
catastrophe of the 20th century,
I knew Russia’s newly independent
neighbors were at risk.
And when Putin talked at the Munich
Security Conference in 2007
about a return to spheres of influence,
I knew he was ready to launch his plan.
It was the language from
the Molotov-Ribbentrop Pact, 1939.
The language Hitler and Stalin
used to divide Europe.
And a year later, in 2008,
Putin invaded the Republic of Georgia.
2014, Ukraine.
It's a paradox, isn't it?
Dictators lie about everything
they have done,
but often they tell us
exactly what they're going to do.
Just listen.
Anyone who is surprised
at Putin's war crimes in Ukraine
must not be aware about his long record,
beginning with the Second Chechen War
in Grozny more than two decades ago.
Vladimir Putin has been
a war criminal from the start.
So in 2005, still being ranked number one,
I retired from professional chess
to form a pro-democracy,
anti-Putin movement in Russia.
As you could see, it didn't go so well.
But it was not about winning or losing.
I knew it was my moral duty
in keeping with the slogan
of Soviet dissidents:
"Do what you must and so be it."
Ah, my friends and critics
both kept telling me,
"Gary, you are a chess player,
you're not a politician.
This is not chess.
You see everything in black and white.
Politics are gray.
You have to compromise."
Really?
Those who peacefully marched
with me for free Russia
are either in exile, like me.
Or in jail, like Alexei Navalny.
Or even murdered like Boris Nemtsov.
Compromise?
Not black and white?
Are you sure?
Compromise with this?
You cannot look at the images
from Ukraine in recent weeks
and say there is no pure evil.
Mariupol destroyed, Bucha slaughtered,
Kramatorsk train station massacred.
And worse is yet to come.
And these horrors
are not from Poland in 1945.
Not from Rwanda in 1994.
Not Aleppo 2016.
This is Europe this week.
How could this happen?
How did we forget what evil can do?
We have lost the generation
that saw World War II firsthand.
Otherwise we reserve
absolute evil for fiction.
In fables, they believe in true evil.
Good is harder to define.
There is no pure good.
If anyone says
they know what pure good is,
it's probably evil.
(Laughter)
In fantasy tales of hobbits
and elves and dwarves,
there was an idea that good comes
in different forms and shapes,
often in conflict.
But they had to be united
when facing absolute evil.
Good will disagree.
Evil says, "No more disagreements ever."
That was life in real Mordor,
the Soviet Union.
That's what Putin wants
for Russia and the world.
We celebrated the end of the Cold War,
but for too long,
we forgot that evil doesn’t die.
It can be buried for a while
under the rubble of the Berlin Wall,
but it grows back
through the cracks of our apathy.
We called it diplomacy
when Putin was embraced
by the leaders of the free world
as equal despite his crimes.
We called it engagement
when we bought trillions of dollars
in Russian oil and gas,
money that built Putin's police state
and his war machine.
Let us call these things what they are:
it was appeasement, it was collaboration.
These days, we prefer to focus
on domestic issues.
We argue about the past,
we fantasize about the future
while ignoring the present.
Once the move is made
you cannot change it.
Acknowledge the wrongdoings of the past,
but do not pretend it can be fixed.
It's the present that must be fixed.
The heroes of the past
were far from perfect.
But the world we live in
is better because of them.
We too cannot be perfect.
But we must always try to be better.
As a chess player,
I know that strategy is the future
impact of present decisions.
However grand our plans are
for two, five, even ten moves ahead,
it's the move that we make now
that determines that future.
Ukraine is now on the front
line of the war,
global war of freedom against tyranny.
The war the free world
didn't want to admit existed.
It cannot be ignored any longer.
Brave Ukrainians
are fighting like hell and dying right now
to remind us not to take
liberty for granted.
Putin,
like every dictator before him,
underestimated the free will
of free people.
They deserve every weapon,
every resource
to win this war.
Because they're fighting for us.
Not only for the whole and free Ukraine.
Everyone who told me
a decade ago I was wrong,
now is telling I'm right.
Unfortunately.
But we're still
repeating the same mistakes
of thinking that we can muddle through
without taking risks,
without taking a stand.
The price of stopping a dictator
always goes up with every delay,
every hesitation.
Meeting evil halfway,
it's still a victory for evil.
Evil tempts us with our weakness,
with our desire for comfort,
being comfortable,
cautious, rational, civilized.
What kind of civilization
[are we] fighting for,
if we allow war crimes and genocide again?
What kind of world are we leaving
for our children and grandchildren
if we only talk of the past and the future
while ignoring murder
and misery in the present?
This is not chess.
This is not a battle
between opposite colors,
but of opposite values.
Freedom, life and love
versus tyranny, death and hatred.
This is not chess.
But sometimes things are black and white.
Sometimes you have to fight
for what you believe.
Or you lose it.
This is not chess.
There are no draws, no compromises
in our battle with true evil.
It's win or lose.
And so we must fight.
And so we must win.
(Ukrainian) Slava Ukraini!
Glory to Ukraine.
Glory to freedom.
Thank you.
(Applause)